hi everyone thanks for being here
so today we're going to talk about your
ex patrons for developers let us start
by introducing ourselves I'm Nicole and
I'm a UI UX designer and I'm also a
design teacher at lo hago which is the
coding bootcamp that teaches web
development in nine weeks and I'm Jojo
Braun I'm a full-stack teacher in
Amsterdam Brussels Lisbon and London so
while coaching developers we noticed
that teaching developers about user
experience and about design is really
important and instead of trying to find
common solutions for common problems why
not tell them about some UX patterns to
use in their everyday code so we said
let's batch these predefined UX patterns
and share them with you today in this
presentation so the term user experience
has been getting a lot of attention
lately but not a lot of people know what
it actually is
and how crucial it is for their success
so UX is all around us and to prove it
let's talk about it in a different
perspective and something that we use
every day the metro how many of you have
had a bad Metro experience so think
about all the combinations of user
experience combined together to give you
this experience of the Metro it's
combination of process guidance of
typography of choice of colors of
simplicity use of contrast familiarity
and a lot of other things that use that
we use to make this user experience and
a lot of testing with users so the point
of the Metro is to make you go where you
want to go as soon as possible and this
is exactly what user experience in web
design is all about it's about a
combination of methods and principles
combined together to make the user happy
so it's about cognitive psychology where
we focus on the users behaviors it's
about usability where you
focus on intuition and makes making
things simple
it's about interaction design and motion
and animation it's about content
strategy where we focus on the voice of
the product it's about visual design
which is where we focus on the interface
to make things to make the product look
trustworthy through design it's about
functionality where we focus on features
to solve problems it's about data
visualization where we design complex
information and it's about information
architecture where we focus on the
structure and functionality so as a
definition user experience design is a
combination of methods with which you
can solve design problems while focusing
on the user so let's focus on two terms
that are widely misused user experience
and user interface it's really simple
they're really different user experience
is just what I've shared with you
earlier but user interface is only the
visual part it's a part of the user
experience process but it's only the
visual design the interface so why am I
telling you this
why am i sharing with you what user
experience is it and what are you expat
earns it's because user experience and
development are like cousins both build
with users both test with users and they
have shared goals so they solve problems
they have shared goals but just
different focus and understanding how
the customers use your product will make
your products much more powerful you'll
be able to get inside the minds of the
people that you build for so what is a
UX pattern exactly there are you
reusable solutions to usability problems
so they're like universal design
conventions they're learned by users and
are now familiar with them so today
we're going to share with you seven
patterns that we think are the most
important things to consider whenever
you're creating a digital product I'm
going to be talking about this
the design perspective of every pattern
and jawed will be tackling the technical
part so the first thing I want to tell
you today is that don't make the user
wait everyone nowadays hate to wait and
everyone is so impatient so everyone
wants their thing right now or else what
they will get bored and just abandon
your website so always always keep it
and keep this in mind that people are
impatient 53% of mobile users abandon
their sites that take longer than 3
seconds to load just 3 seconds
that's how impatient people are nowadays
so to tackle this problem let's take a
look at two examples of loading a
website so the first one is a normal
loading where everything loads together
at the same time so we're used to this
usually we we look at we go into the
website wait for some seconds it depends
how heavy the website is and then BOOM
everything loads whereas a progressive
loading is where things load one after
the other so component after component
with a loading state so this is a bit
more satisfying whereas the first
example is if it's frustrating so the
second one reduces the perception of
time and reduces the users uncertainty
so let's see how we can do websites that
load this way so we're going to start by
identifying the three main events that
happen whenever user is loading our page
and the first one is the first thing and
this is a more technical preview of what
Nicole showed us unoptimized rendering
could could show the user a wide screen
for around a few seconds and then
suddenly everything loads
whereas optimized rendering is where we
have everything loading progressively so
what I'm gonna do now is I'm gonna show
you a snippet off of an index.html
because this problem is quite frequent
on the web so I want to show you why it
exists so if we take a look at this
example we're loading just the CSS for
at the beginning we have a bunch of HTML
and loading script at the end and if we
take this to the network top with a 3G
with the 3G throttle connection you can
see that we're loading the index the
image the JavaScript and the CSS the
whole thing takes 5 seconds to load and
in this particular scenario this is
where the browser starts rendering
rendering on the screen so I want to ask
you a question what is the browser
waiting for before it can actually
render JavaScript it's obvious anything
else the start sheet so it's not very
obvious but the browser is also waiting
for CSS because if the browser doesn't
wait for CSS it's going to show you some
content and then there will be a flash
of unstyled content when the CSS is
returned back to the page so this is why
by default we say that javascript and
CSS are both blocking they both block
rendering so we're going to explore one
of the ways to unblock rendering and
let's start by seeing this for CSS
so we're gonna unblock rendering for CSS
by first of all inlining critical CSS
has anyone done this before so we inline
critical CSS in the head and then for
the rest of the CSS we dynamically
injected at the end what do I mean by
critical CSS well just the basic amount
of styles or the basic styles that you
would require as soon as possible the
things that you want to load or paint as
soon as possible so in this example I'm
just changing the background color of
the body removing the margin and
changing the background color of the
header and for JavaScript unlocking
JavaScript is much easier you just add
the async attribute on the script tag
now this works if you if you don't if
you have only one script tag if you've
got multiple ones and you need to
guarantee execution order you have to
use the defer attribute in case your
scripts depend on each other now after
applying all of these optimizations this
is what we'll have inline Styles
critical CSS this shouldn't be too much
CSS just a few lines of CSS the same
HTML async scripts and inside those
scripts you'll be loading the other CSS
asynchronously and now let's take it to
the test
exact same thing it still takes 5
seconds but now we are able to render at
200 milliseconds so let me show you side
by side by just working more with the
browser you're able to start rendering
as soon as possible and this is a
pattern we see a lot in native apps when
you open facebook facebook on Android or
on iOS as soon as possible you'll see
something that's painted and this is why
this is a pattern we should follow a lot
on the web as well now let's take this
concept little further and let's talk
about the app shell has anyone done
options before so the options just the
minimal HTML CSS and possibly JavaScript
that powers our user interface so let's
take a look at the same example and
highlight the option that's the app
shell it's like the container where the
content that has loaded will go into it
so once again this is the app shell and
one
the content has loaded it will go inside
the application shelf so how can we
achieve this it's exactly the same thing
we've done I just want to show you that
you can create an app shell with just
like 30 or 20 lines of CSS this is a
floating action button and that's the
code for it and we're just changing the
background color removing the margin and
giving a background color to the header
as well so it's just about about the way
you're designing it about the way you're
coding it as well and after showing the
app shell we have another event which is
the first meaningful paint that's
because the option is not that
meaningful to the user it's not showing
personalized content it's just showing
that the app is being responsive to our
actions so the first meaningful paint we
all see it here is right now so just
when the content loads on the screen and
that's we have to make sure that the
first meaningful paint does not take a
long time after the app shell
and then the third step is ready when
your app is ready for interaction and
this is the most important part because
a lot of times we've got the content
inside in front of you but you cannot
interact with it and the reason behind
it
JavaScript so this is a real trace that
I took from nasa.gov
on my macbook pro with only five times
CPU throttling the main threat was
blocked for more than eight seconds just
parsing the vendor the JavaScript so we
do we don't want to block the main
thread just because we want to parse big
javascript files so I'm gonna give you
some possible shalu's solutions in order
to ship less JavaScript and the first
one is by using source map Explorer has
anyone used it before so source map
Explorer is just a node module that
explains more about the content inside
your vendor touches so this has helped
many teams understand why they're
shipping jQuery twice or why are they
shipping the whole load out library
whereas you only need one function from
it so by taking a closer look into your
vendor the JavaScript you'll be able to
trim about 10 20 or even more 20% or 20%
from your vendor to JavaScript and you
can also get into code splitting
especially if you're using webpack that
way you'll be able to push only the
minimum amount of JavaScript for every
single file and the reason why this is a
good thing is if you need to reinvent it
this home the JavaScript you don't have
to reinvent your whole app the
javascript file which is probably around
1 megabyte so judges told us how
important it is to load things fast and
progressively but that is not enough
showing good content at the first load
is also important so above the fold is a
term borrowed from the newspaper
industry which refers to what is visible
above the page before loading before
scrolling so of course the exact
location of the fold will defer for
devices but the concept still matters so
what we find at the top of the page well
that will helps us decide
if we want to continue scrolling or
abandon the page so that's why building
a story above the fold by creating a
glimpse of interesting information will
make us engage with the website and
scroll to view more so always prioritize
the content that lead the user down the
page now let's move on to the second
pattern we shouldn't forget that the web
is fluid which means it will defer on so
many scenarios nowadays it's not static
it will change which means we have to
consider different states of what design
according to Vince Spearman in his
article the nine states of design he
said as we learn to craft systems rather
than pages we must invest effort into
shaping this often missed missed states
of design so what does he mean by these
missed States let's see the first state
of design is the nothing state this is
where before your item does something
before your product shows something so
maybe your component didn't do anything
yet or the first time the user sees it
this is the nothing state the loading
States is where we inform people that
the system is loading and we give them
feedback to to the visual so this will
also reduce the perception of time and
it will give the user something to look
at while waiting the third state is the
non state so this is where you have no
data no items nothing to show instead of
showing showing just a blank screen why
not use this opportunity to show the
user something to make them engage so
the difference between this state and
the nothing state that we saw on the
first one is that the nothing state is
before something happens
whereas this one can happen anytime as
long as it's empty so whenever I swiped
everything as done in Google inbox I
always feel like I accomplished
something today when I see this empty
state the one state is when you have one
item to show
in a list for example or one item left
so we also have to consider this is one
state what happens when you have one of
something the some state is basically
the ideal state this is where I have
some items in a list for example the too
many states is where you have too many
things and we have to think about what
happens when it when this happens so we
add a pagination we add a load more we
add automatic loading so I have to think
about that now the incorrect state is
where we have an error so when when we
have an error the user has to know that
this error happened why it happened and
what can they do about it
if the correct state is the exact
opposite when something is correct and
we sometimes we have to tell the user
that is correct for example when we
enter an email address or a password so
this is where you tell the user that
you're good to go
the done state is when we have a correct
input and it's received by the app and
we have to tell the user that is done
that they don't have to worry anymore
so always have a checklist of these nine
states of design whenever you're
creating something a digital product in
order to make it more consistent and to
consider different states now building
trust and credibility is one of the most
important things about user experience
why do you think we use air B&B and
PayPal isn't it because we trust them
and that we're familiar with them and we
find comfort with them so what makes an
app trustworthy first having an
interface that actually works and it is
not broken is the most important thing
to have so here's a hierarchy of design
needs that tells us how to make
something trustworthy so the first thing
we have to consider is that the website
should be functional and meet in that it
should meet some basic functional needs
the second thing is that it has to be
reliable so it has to provide consistent
performance
it has to be reusable easy to use
without difficulty users should do more
and better and quicker in our website
and it should be memorable so everything
we do on the website we should remember
it later on so we could come back to it
reversibility is a design principle that
says people should be able to recover
from their mistake this also reinforces
trust with the product now another way
to earn trust with the user is to use
good timing especially for notifications
and asking for permissions for example
so we should tell them where when they
should care about the thing we're
telling them about and we shouldn't
interrupt them and force them to pay
attention on something they don't want
to see right now
so here's an example of a bad timing of
asking for permissions nothing can be
more annoying than opening website and
immediately asking for your location
without relevant contacts without
anything it confuses the user and it
will make them go away instead if you
ask politely and at the right time to
ask for permissions in a respectful way
this will reinforce trust with the user
so for example in google hangouts
after you've after you go and to find
your friends and act tap next
then they will ask you for access to
your contacts so this is a respectful
way and makes sense and it's just
respectful so let's see why this bad
timing issue happens to begin with so
there must be a problem why this issue
happens on especially on the web and the
root of this issue is actually the
navigator dot geo location dot get
current position the problem with that
endpoint with that JavaScript API is
that there was no way for us developers
to know if the user has given us
permission or not and the only way for
us to figure it out was to call this
method and then this method would show
the location permission again so that's
why a lot of websites had the
the website would like to get access to
your location on the first screen on the
first loading screen so how can you fix
that this is going to be fixed using the
permission API it still doesn't have
full browser support it's supported on
Chrome Firefox Opera and Chrome for
Android hopefully coming soon in edge
and Safari but not sure about it and it
just allows you to query for permissions
so you're basically asking the browser
do I have permission to use geolocation
and then the browser will tell you the
state and you can also listen for change
events so whenever you previously had
low key access but now you don't have to
or even the opposite way so this should
fix the problem that we've had on the
web for permissions using functional
animation and installer animations that
have clear logical purpose while being
your user interface to life
so there are lots of types of
transitions for example navigational
transitions are movements between States
from high-level view to a detailed view
for example and Google uses this concept
in their material design components in
Google Calendar they use this
navigational transition to navigate from
an event to event details so these kinds
of transitions focus on the component
that we navigated to also gestural
navigations allow us to swipe to use
swipe gesture to navigate between
different views so here in Google inbox
in their app they use this gesture
navigation to swipe and close an open
email message but let's see what makes a
good transition we now know that
transitions smoothly transport users
between navigational contacts but what
really makes them good transitions so
first a transition has to be responsive
and by responsive I don't need
responsive for the device but responsive
with the tap of the user now here it's
not showing the ripple effect it should
be showing but maybe because of the high
contrast but when when the user taps on
somewhere or clicks
somewhere there should be a feedback
mechanism here that the user clicked
here transition also should be natural
every movement we do should be inspired
by forces in the real world this is what
makes it a good transition a transition
also has to be quick so the movement
should be fast enough that it doesn't
cause waiting for it like this one a
transition also has to be clear so
always keep animation clear and the
duration of it is under 300 milliseconds
so transitions will make your app look
smooth and delightful to use but there
are scenarios where sometimes
transitions lag even though we worked
really hard on them to make them smooth
so if if a transition lags it will it
will hurt our user experience instead of
making it better so let's see how we can
make transitions that don't lag so I'm a
big fan of material design and the first
time I was looking at on to these
animations I thought there must be very
easy right I mean he's just animating
the width animating the height I'll use
css3 I should be super fast right but
unfortunately that's not the answer so I
want to tell you quickly what happens
from Dom to pixels on the screen so what
is the pipeline that the browsers follow
in order to draw animations on the
screen and after understanding this
you'll be able to know why sometimes
transitions can hurt the user experience
if they were lagging and how to make
them even faster so this is the pipeline
that most browsers follow the first up
there are five steps and the first step
is when we trigger the animation so we
call it JavaScript but you can trigger
it either using JavaScript or CSS and
then the next step is when the browser
recalculates the starts so this is when
the browser figures out okay this class
this class applies to this element and
these properties apply to this element
and then afterwards the browser has to
calculate the layout and the layout is
just the geometry of the page so
everything that used to have percentages
in
Vantage's in it will become fixed with
will be calculated into fixed pixels so
that's an example of the geometry of
Airbnb landing page so everything will
have like 200 pixels x 300 pixels etc
and then after calculate calculating the
geometry the browser has to paint those
pixels in two different layers because
the navbar is probably on a layer the
the landing page is probably on another
layer and finally the compositor will
merge all of these into the screen and
draw it onto the screen so those are the
five steps and now what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna map some CSS properties to one
of the last three sections of the
pipeline and we can actually map with
height margin top left to the layout
face because if you change the width the
browser has to do to redo layout and for
the paint we can map background image
background color box shadow and border
radius and finally the compositor can
take care of properties such as
transform and opacity so armed with this
knowledge I'm gonna show you three
animation scenarios and we're going to
see how the browser is able to animate
them on every single frame the first
scenario is what happens if we animate
by changing the width or left or top or
margin so we change the width so the
browser has to recalculate the layout we
have a new layout so the browser has to
do paint again and the compositor has to
merge everything back onto the screen
again so this is gonna happen on every
single frame so imagine how expensive
this is and we only have a limited very
limited amount of time to finish this so
that's why animations with width will
actually struggle and the second
scenario what happens if we change the
background color well there's no way
that the background that changing the
background color can affect the geometry
of the page so the browser is gonna skip
the layout and it's gonna do paint and
then compositing you can probably see
where I'm going with this what happens
if we animate using transform or opacity
well the browser is going to skip layout
and paint and immediately jump to the
compositor so that's why this is the
this is the most desirable for high
pressure points and when I say high
pressure points are not talking about
small transitions like if you have a
background color and you want to change
if you have a button and you want to
change the background color that's fine
if you change the background color but
once you're doing whole page transitions
or dialogue transitions you have to be
careful and you have to work with the
browser more and that's why we can
conclude that there are four properties
there are four things that the browser
can animate cheaply so you can move an
element using transform translate you
can make it bigger or smaller using the
scale and you can rotate it and you can
even change the opacity that's because
the compositor can take care of these in
most scenarios and make it fast so what
does it mean for us as developers it
means that we have to always think
whenever we have a high-pressure point
in terms of these four properties so
never think about animating using width
or height always see if you can do it
using scale never try to move the
element using top and laughs try to do
it using translate so I've prepared a
small demo here and I'll show you how
the browser why it's actually important
to do this so this demo is actually
prepared by Paul Irish from the chrome
team and I have a Mac I'll have to
okay so you can see here I have a
MacBook and that is animating that's
okay and the way it's animating is by
using the left property and this is a
heavy MacBook what I mean by heavy is
that there are a lot of box shadows and
that's because we're putting the browser
to the test so what I'm gonna do now is
I'm gonna go ahead and add a few mark
books but before doing that actually I
will open the inspector and enable go to
Timeline and enable CPU throttling
because I want to simulate mobile
performance so I'm gonna emulate five
times scipio throttling and I'm gonna
add a few mark books and you can see
after adding a few mark books the
animation is not smooth anymore that's
because the browser is probably doing a
lot of work whereas if I go clear this
and apply the battery of transform of
animating this by using transform
translate X of 500 pixels even with CPU
throttling we still have CPU throttling
you can see that I can add up to 100 or
even more mark books and the performance
will still be really fast so I still
want to show you a visualization behind
this I want to show you how much work
the browser is doing so I will revert
once again to the slow animation and
opened up tools press escape click on
the overflow menu and go to rendering
and I'm gonna enable paint flashing so
the browser is gonna paint a green
square whenever it's doing paint so when
is the browser doing paint on every
single frame and if I add another
MacBook well the browser is repainting
every mark book on every single frame so
now if I go and revert to the fast
animation we have we still have paint
flashing and it seems the browser only
has to paint the mark book once once it
brings it into the screen
and then this is the compositor that's
animating everything so this is how you
can visualize sometimes that the browser
is doing way more work than it should be
with doing so that's why you are able to
achieve fast transitions in the scenario
we always have to consider that the user
might lose connectivity someday when
they're using your website so we don't
want to break their user experience when
they're using our app and something
happens and not only if it's if they're
disconnected from the internet but also
if the internet is slow so there's
always this in between online and
offline it happens a lot so let's see
these two examples
imagine you are sending a text and
you'll go into the Metro and the
Internet is gone on whatsapp on the
iPhone you can't really continue texting
anymore you have to just stop because
the Internet is gone so this is what
what I mean by breaking the experience
while on the Android you can just
continue texting and it will be received
received well when the Internet is back
on so users shouldn't feel offline when
they're using the your website this
should be feeling like they're using
like nothing happened and when the
Internet is back on it will work again
so let's see how we can do websites that
work offline the key point of making a
website work offline is by adding a
service worker and the service worker is
just a script that is run by the browser
in the background and independently from
your web page and this actually opens up
a lot of possibilities to do push
notifications work offline intercepting
requests and even background sync but
we're going to follow two strategies
here in order to to be able to serve an
offline version to our users the first
strategy is by pre-caching our main
content and then the other one is
dynamic caching so let's start by
pre-caching so what we want a pre cache
is actually the app shell that we
defined earlier in the first UX pattern
so we have the app shell and we want to
precache it because we want to serve
this independently from the natural
condition if the network is slow if we
are offline we want to always ship the
app app shop and this is what happens in
native apps if you open the Facebook app
even when you're offline you will get
the whole app shell first and then
you'll get a message that you are
offline
and this is a comparison before and
after adding a serviceworker and these
are the main files that we required for
the upshot for example the index.html
the logo and the speed dial they are
being served from the network whereas
after installing a serviceworker they
are being installed reliably from a
serviceworker
and what this means is that we are able
to show a custom offline experience now
I know this is not super nice but this
is only the first step of it instead of
showing the offline dinosaur we are able
to show our own custom offline
experience so now let's take it step
further and see if we can make our app
work offline and this is where dynamic
dynamic caching comes in place and
dynamic caching for dynamic caching to
work we have to use one of those three
strategies cache first network first or
fastest so I'm going to show you how
they work this is cache first so this is
a page and it's being intercepted by a
serviceworker and the green dot is a
natural Creek West so let's see how it
works
Network request goes out of the page it
gets intercepted by a serviceworker and
then goes to the cache and then the
cache will return the data back to the
page so this is nice if you know you've
got some data on the cache and you want
to read it independently from natural
condition now network first is when you
have once again a natural request coming
out of the page and then the
serviceworker will go to the network but
for some reason the network is gonna
fail and this happens a lot
it could happen if you go offline it
could happen if you have unreliable
internet connection
so what happens now is that the request
is gonna backtrack to the serviceworker
and then get forwarded to the cache get
the data that you want and then forward
back to the page so what this means is
we try to get the content the most
recent content from the network but in
case it fails we don't just fail we just
return some stale content from the cache
and the last one which is fastest or
stale while revalidate slightly more
complicated but more interesting we have
a network request that gets intercepted
by a serviceworker
which then spawns two identical requests
one going to the network and one going
to the cache
now obviously the cache is going to
return much faster than the network but
then what happens is that the response
from the network is going to update the
cache for the next time we use it so
this allows you to use stale content
from the cache immediately while always
updating the content of the cache
whenever we get a response back from the
network so you could use a mix of these
strategies depending on what content
you're loading so if you're loading
critical content you'd use Network first
if you don't care about serving stale
content you would use this one and if
you want to get a little bit technical
this is a configuration file for
sw-precache which allows you to do
everything I've told you about so far
this is how you cache the app shell you
define which files you want to pre cache
which files you want to be part of the
app shell and this is how you specify
blind sorry this is how you specify
dynamic caching by specifying a URL
pattern so whenever I go and get an API
from the API the list of countries this
is a regular expression then I will use
the cash first handler
how many of you have had a bad mobile
experience I know we always think that
the desktop or laptop is the majority of
the users but it's not it's the that's
because we use the laptop all the time
but actually if you're not making your
mobile visitors happy you're
disappointing the majority of the people
who are using your website mobile users
are growing and growing and growing and
according to research by Morgan Stanley
the number of global users of mobile are
growing and growing every year and it's
surpassed the number of desktop users
and that's in 2015 so it's still growing
even more and surprisingly 7 and 10
users prefer mobile website over mobile
apps across devices so that's why we
have to invest time to work on web apps
or websites that work on mobile to make
them smooth fast and as native as
possible what I'm going to talk about
right now has a prerequisite of making
your app work offline and assuming we've
made our app work offline we can make it
as a progressive web app to benefit off
native functionalities or at least
native behavior so we have to use a web
app manifest and the web app manifest is
a JSON file that tells the browser more
about the content of the website so this
is a an example of a manifest file for
Foursquare for example you specify like
a short name named theme color
background color a lot of options and
you can see on the right how it affects
the workflow of adding to homescreen so
for example the user has added it to his
home screen now when you click on it you
will get a splash screen and you can see
that this is chrome now or this is the
browser that's opening our progressive
web app but the user doesn't know this
because it looks like a progressive web
app just by defining this manifest file
and the main point here is the display
stand-alone which hides all of the stuff
that are related to the browser so once
you've made your app work offline
take the extra step and make it as a
progressive web app by adding the web
app manifest and once you've done that
the browser will actually go ahead and
ask your users we noticed you're using
this app would you like to add it to
your home screen instead of the user
going to the overflow menu and adding to
home screen so this has obviously
positive effects on the user experience
and especially that users your users
will have you on their icon on their
desktop now the browser doesn't show
this for all the web sites obviously
there must be some criteria first of all
you need to have a web app manifest a
valid web app manifest you need to have
a registered service worker and you need
to be running on HTTPS of course
actually all the service worker
functionality only work on HTTPS and the
last criteria is the browser will wait
for you to visit the web site once then
at least five minutes and then the next
time you go to this website it will ask
you if we want to add it to the home
screen while this is nice for real users
it's quite annoying for us developers to
test you'll have to push code go to the
web site get coffee etc so actually if
there's a there's a chrome flag you can
go to the chrome flags and bypass banner
engagement sharks so that's way the
first time we go into progressive web
app the browser will ask you and you
will see if it works or not so now we've
got an icon on the home screen but you
actually have to meet user expectations
because you should remember that our
users don't even know that the term PWA
or progressive web app exists they don't
know that this is the browser hiding and
showing you content in a web browser if
they have an icon on the screen then
they think this is a native app and
which means it should behave like a
native app so that's why there's the
awesome chrome plugin and even node
module called lighthouse which allows
you to understand where your doing good
in terms of your ex and where you could
have some improvements so for example it
shows you the first meaningful paint it
makes sure you have a registered service
worker it has a lot of performance
metrics so you can use this as a crow
plugin or even as a node module as part
of your continuous integration do check
it out it's awesome and my personal tip
is to always continuously test on real
mobile devices so make this as part of
your developer routine so we always test
on chrome dev tools on a MacBook Pro or
on a lenovo but that's not going to
simulate what happens on mobile and you
can also use throttling features in
chrome also do use them but make sure
that they do not replace real testing on
real devices I I personally use a lot of
CPU throttling and network throttling as
well now enough technicalities for today
let's move on to something different
how to use persuasion to make the users
engage more in our website so first off
curiosity we crave more when teased with
is just interesting information that's
why revealing a bit of information of
something will make the user engage more
it will teach them to into taking action
to deviant more so this will keep the
user is hanging on for example in your
ex pin they play on curiosity with Adams
video in the background of their app
actually working so this really makes us
want to click on that input enter our
email in order to try it on because we
can see how it functions in the
background scarcity is when something
has a limit and when something is being
scarce we perceive it as more desirable
and more valuable for example in
CheapOair they use scarcity to engage
users into booking these these last two
tickets so they say they're only two
tickets left at this price and if you
don't book it now your flyer is gone so
this limited amount offers to push users
to make a decision now rather than later
reward is when we sum we want
encouragement in a sense of reward and
we saw something similar to that earlier
so building this
of reward into the users user experience
will make them engage more and come back
to your website for example in duolingo
they you receive point as a user you
receive funds and badges as you complete
different courses so when you see this
percentage 39% this will hook the users
and will wait will make them come back
to finish them we always consider the
actions of others in new and unfamiliar
situations so that's why we always show
that others are using our product and
that they like it and the perfect
example of this is how we add
testimonials and our website or use
cases so we assure visitors that the
product is well respected and frequently
used by their similar others so let's
recap everything we now know that to
make our website have a better user
experience we shouldn't make our users
wait we should also consider the
different states of Web Design we should
earn the users trust enhance the user
experience with smooth transitions make
the website work offline optimize the
website for mobile and play on
persuasion patterns so by doing all
these smart patterns you will engage the
users make them come back and talk about
your product
always remember that these UX patterns
are a starting point not an end so you
can always put your unique twist on any
UX pattern once you know what makes it
work there are many other UX patterns
that you can find online if you're
interested in knowing more about these
you can find this list of resources that
we use to create this presentation I
hope you enjoyed the talk and we're
happy to answer your questions
[Applause]